eine tasse kaffee ein stück brot mehr
braucht es nicht damit roman beele sich
als mensch fühlt als gleicher unter
gleichen in rom er ist eigentlich
obdachlos einer am rande der
gesellschaft ohne papiere ohne
perspektive manchmal kann schon ein
einfaches frühstück die welt bedeuten
das ist eine unglaubliche freude eine
ungeheure befriedigung in den genuss der
nächstenliebe von missio band zu kommen
müssen oder einfach nur pennen so nennen
ihn alle
eigentlich heißt der ahmed ben
abderrahman und kommt aus marokko vor 19
jahren hatte in brüssel sein hotel
eröffnet und es mozart genannt ein stein
gewordenes orientalisches märchen ein
drei-sterne-hotel zu bunt wie miss you
bands lebensgeschichte und es sind auch
nicht immer voll
vor allem im winter januar februar wenn
es kalt ist lasse ich die menschen
herein
wissen sie ich versetze mich an ihre
stelle
wenn sie mich dann mit dankbaren augen
ansehen dann ist mir das eine freude und
so öffnet seine tür für menschen in not
jeder bekommt hier ein frühstück und oft
auch ein zimmer egal ob bezahlen kann
oder nicht
und bisher hat sich noch keiner der
zahlenden gäste beschwert sagt benning
gegenteil
das ist doch fantastisch ich wünschte es
gäbe mehr menschen wie ihn darüber kann
man doch nur froh sein
es gibt so viel unglück in der welt
es ist immer das gleiche lied ohne
aufenthaltserlaubnis keine
arbeitserlaubnis ohne arbeit keine
aufenthaltserlaubnis dabei hatte rohmer
jahrelang arbeit in einem malerei
betrieb doch irgendwann gab es nicht
mehr genug zu tun sein chef musste ihn
entlassen
die arbeitserlaubnis war damit weg nach
einem halben jahr konnte er seine
wohnung nicht mehr bezahlen und landete
auf der straße über das leben auf der
straße spricht roma nicht viel und wenn
dann vermeidet er fast ängstlich über
sich selbst zu sprechen erzählt nur von
den anderen vom leben auf der straße
hier am hintereingang einer kirche im
zentrum brüssels hatte er seinen
schlafplatz viele monate ein
gefährliches leben
wissen sie wenn jungs zu sieben oder
acht sind und angetrunken dann kann
alles passieren
die drehen durch werden gewalttätig
regen sich über alles auf die kümmern
sich einen dreck um das leben der leute
die hier schlafen die schlafplätze sind
picobello sauber und aufgeräumt
die leute die hier schlafen sagt roma
sind keine class keine drogen kein
alkohol sondern einfach nur pech im
leben
auf der anderen seite der kirche
zeitungsformat liegen die dänin der
alkohol das leben kaputt macht es sieht
anders aus dort dann traf roman sieben
monate ist das her seitdem blüht roma
hier ein dach über dem kopf ein
richtiges bett eine saubere dusche roma
wird diesen moment nie vergessen
das ist besser als bei mir zuhause
dusche im zimmer und ein fernseher
als ich hier reinkam und das bild vom
soldaten gesehen habe habe ich gedacht
wow das muss ich tun nicht aufgeben
kämpfen
und so zieht er los bewaffnet mit seinen
papieren mit niemand geringerem als der
präsidentin des belgischen senats will
erheben
der polizist am haupteingang schickt ihn
nicht weg sondern erklärt freundlich den
weg zum besucher eingang
vielleicht ist es die anwesenheit
unserer kamera war tatsächlich kommt
nach einiger zeit jemand um sich romans
fall anzuhören und verspricht sich darum
zu kümmern
eine riesenüberraschung ich bin sehr
zufrieden ich habe den sprecher der
senats präsidentin getroffen das ist ein
schritt nach vorn
und dann geht es um mal wieder wie so
vielen vor ihm im hotel mozart
er muss warten auf den anruf vom senat
hoffen darauf dass endlich etwas besser
wird in seinem leben das warten sagt er
ist das schwerste